there are countless different ways to
train from working out like an old-time
strongman to performing calisthenics to
relying on the big lists however is my
belief that rather than sticking to just
one of these options the best results
come from mixing and matching the best
techniques from each with that in mind
here are some exercises you can borrow
from different disciplines that can
benefit you in multiple amazing ways no
matter your goals
[Music]
the Cossacks squat the Cossacks squat is
a great moon that works really well as a
progression towards the pistol squats
whilst also improving mobility and
strength it's a great option for
bodyweight leg training and of course
you can add extra weight if you wish to
perform the movement you'll simply squat
down low onto one leg while keeping the
other stretched out to the side try to
get as low as you can so that your butt
rest against your heel to increase the
challenge you can grab a kettlebell to
add weight it's a position that you'll
find is actively useful in many sports
effectively a sideways lunge it will
also build mobility for sidekicks and
roundhouse kicks if you currently have
no movements that train you in the
frontal plane which is likely for a lot
of people then it becomes even more
valuable quasi isometric squat speaking
of squats another fantastic squatting
movement is the quasi isometric squat
for those that haven't seen my previous
videos on this a quasi isometric
movement is one performed extremely
slowly almost as though you were
motionless it should take anywhere from
30 to 120 seconds in total to perform
the entire movement so you might be
using 30 or 60 seconds each for the
concentric and eccentric portions this
sounds easy until you try and do it and
then notice your legs shaking like mad
normally we accelerate through those
weakest parts of the movement allowing
the momentum to do most of the work we
are strangely weak at certain points
within regular ranges of motion and
using it quasi isometric we'll fix that
not only that but this slow movement
into deep squat will improve your
mobility and you'll also be able to
polish up your technique by feeling
where your weight is distributed if
there's any curve in your spine etc the
one-armed push-up the one-armed push-up
or one-armed and one-legged push-up is
an amazing bodyweight move for building
PEC tricep and shoulder strength by
focusing your weight on just one side
you essentially create a push-up that is
twice as difficult as it otherwise would
be but more than that the one-armed
push-up also moves the center of gravity
away from your anchor to the ground
creating leverage and rotational force
as well as pushing the body up and down
you also need to concentrate on not
allowing it to twist to the ground this
engages the obliques and builds amazing
stability making you hard to push over
and increasing your body control and
proprioception as an added bonus it
looks cool to see you dopes lanch pushup
the pseudo planche push up is a push up
variation used in calisthenics and
gymnastic strength training to develop
the necessary
beats to perform planche this involves
moving the arms further down the body so
that you're leaning forward over them is
up to you if you wish to rotate the
hands at the same time or keep them
facing forwards but the latter will
require and therefore build greater
wrist strength and stability meanwhile
you'll also be developing your straight
arm strength as the elbow should be
facing forwards and locking out at the
top of each rep with the scapula
protracted the offset weight once again
increases the relative resistance but
the angle places the force more squarely
on the shoulders and the anterior delts
in particular my anterior deltoids have
ballooned since I've been performing
these which has really enhanced my
physique it's also important to keep the
torso in the hollow body position
contracting the ABS and engaging the
pelvis with the posterior pelvic tilt
this means that you'll be training your
core simultaneously while working on
posture and body awareness obviously
this can help you to develop the planche
but on its own it has a lot of benefits
and crossover for other aspects of your
performance dumbbell runners are a
time-saving move I used a lot when I was
training more as a bodybuilder actually
learn them from Sylvester Stallone's
book sly moves turns out though it has a
bunch of other benefits too to perform
grab a dumbbell in each hand using a
hammer grip now perform a hammer curl on
one side while raising the shoulder and
a tricep kickback on the other side then
you're going to slowly swap sides in a
continuous movement essentially looks
like you're running in slow motion ala
Baywatch while holding dumbbells to
perform this movement you'll of course
need to use a slightly lighter weight
seeing as you'll be able to kick back
much less than you can curl what's cool
about this is the muscles are under
constant tension as they go through the
concentric and eccentric phases this
builds up a whole lot of metabolic
stress for a great burn and a high
likelihood of hypertrophy another
benefit is you'll be able to hit the
deltoids the biceps the triceps all
simultaneously this is ideal for an arms
routine when you're short on time and it
requires a certain amount of
coordination as a hybrid exercise
combining at least two movements
cartwheels you probably didn't expect to
see this here but there are actually
lots of benefits to performing
cartwheels the truth is that even for
those of us who train regularly were
generally quite slow moving a static we
tend to lift things in a straight line
from a steel position as children on the
other hand we'd throw ourselves about
rolie polie attempt handstands and more
and we were much more limber and far
less prone to injury as a result this
kind of fast movement in inversion
throws the body in the brain through
alley
hitting it with all kinds of sensory
information and requiring rapid
alterations in muscle tone and position
this builds coordination mind muscle
connection and the youthful vigor that
many of us have lost as an added bonus
cartwheels also improves mobility in the
hips and the shoulders and there another
movement in the frontal plane not only
that this kind of movement also subjects
the body to impacts to help strengthen
the joints and the bones and as an added
bonus is a perfect progression towards
other movements like aerials B twists
and even hamstrings go both left and
right to develop that ambidexterity T
loaded carries the loaded carries a
movement that can in some ways be
considered the most functional movement
of them all that's because it's
concerned with simply moving a heavy
object from point A to point B which is
something you actually do in real life
this builds the traps to a large degree
maintain a slight shoulder shrug avoid
fully depressing the scapula trains the
erector spinae in core to keep you
upright improves your gait and offers a
contralateral exercise for enhanced
coordination it develops grip and
forearm strength improves hip strength
and may even enhance jump height balance
and stability of course this is also a
great form of resistance cardio as
you'll be using a lot more energy to
move it can increase bone density too
simply due to your body being under a
heavy load for longer I love when a
workout is extremely simple but also has
very noticeable and undeniable impacts
on your body just grab 220 kilogram
kettlebells or maybe 136 kilogram
kettlebell and go for a mile walk the
next day you'll feel as though you had a
hugely effective whole body workout
because you have and as you progress you
can simply increase the weight the
distance the time to completion or even
the way that you're holding the weights
weighted monkey bars
unfortunately not everyone reading this
is likely to have access to monkey bars
nor a means of adding weight to their
bodies but if you're fortunate enough to
have this opportunity take it the monkey
bars in general are a fantastic workout
for the entire upper body we'll be
performing an isometric contraction to
keep your body aloft while also opening
up the shoulders by transitioning your
weight onto just one arm you'll be
preparing for moves like the one arms
pull up and one-armed hang you'll also
require a huge amount of grip strength
to stay up there and you'll find it
surprisingly a tough core workout as you
use your abs and obliques to help swing
yourself forwards to the next
also awesome is taking off the weight
and swinging around freestyle that's a
fun way to challenge your pulling
strength in all kinds of different
angles finally the gamma cast is
considered the king exercise of the club
bells take a club bell and hold it in
both hands in front of you elbows bent
and supporting the weight now leading
with the tip circle the club Bell behind
your head in a clockwise motion and then
return to the starting position pause
then repeat again heading the other way
like a kettlebell swing this movement is
ballistic in nature this is an explosive
movement utilizing the stretch
shortening cycle with the goal being to
accelerate a load as fast as possible
without a deceleration phase think of it
like a longer plyometric exercise unlike
the kettlebell swing though the camera
cast is aimed at the scapular humeral
thoracic articulation requiring you to
rotate your shoulders against a
constantly changing force this is great
for opening up the shoulders and
increasing strength and stability but it
also requires a similar amount of
stability in the core and legs to keep
the body still against the g-forces
there's very little like it
so those are just some of my favorite
often overlooked movements from a host
of different disciplines that can build
a multiple different attributes
simultaneously that you may otherwise be
missing let me know your favorites in
the comments below and stay tuned
because I'm likely to do more of these
kinds of videos in future the previous
one was very popular don't find this
video useful interesting guys if you did
then please leave a like please chat
around that helped me out immensely if
you like this kind of training then
check out my ebook and training program
super functional training you can find
the link in the description down below
head over to the blog for more like this
or hit subscribe and I'll see you next
time thanks a ton for watching and bye
for now